so for a couple years now we've done
regular segments on ufos because there
is a lot of evidence that maybe there's
something
to this thing and then in the space of
the last
month or two we've been drowned with
evidence
by the way on sunday we learned no big
deal that
ufos have been flying into restricted
airspace
off the coast of virginia every day for
years we learned this sunday night in 60
minutes one former navy commander
david fravor said he witnessed ufo
flying over the pacific ocean
in november of 2004. and we saw this
little white
tic tac looking object and it's just
kind of moving above the white water
area
as dietrich circled above fravor went in
for a closer look sort of spiraling down
the tic tacs don't point north-south
it goes and just turns abruptly
and starts mirroring me so as i'm coming
down it starts coming up
so it's it's mimicking your moves yeah
it was where we were there
he said it was about the size of his
f-18 with no
markings no wings no exhaust plumes
too i'll see how close i can get so i go
like this and it's climbing still
and when it gets right in front of me it
just disappears
so we talked to david fravor last night
and he told us something that was
fascinating that we didn't know
so this happens he sees the ufo very
clearly while flying a military jet in
2004
but the military doesn't save the tape
of the incident or any of the data on
the ship
why wouldn't you it's clearly a security
risk but you ignore it
how many other ufos have been ignored by
the u.s military how many others have
been
hidden leslie keene is one of the few
people who might know the answer to that
question she's the author of ufos
generals pilots and government officials
go on the record
she joins us tonight leslie thanks so
much for coming on
tucker this is baffling on it well i'm
so glad that you're here
it's baffling on a bunch of different
levels but the most basic is
this has happened a lot not just a few
times but according to 60 minutes on
sunday
every day for years what is the
military's response to this been
it is amazing and i didn't even know
until last night that some of the data
had been confiscated or at least we
don't know where it is i mean the
military's response so far has been a
lot better than it used to be tucker
i've been covering this this story for
20 years and you know that we we're in a
we're in a real sea change right now
where the military is acknowledging that
these
things are real of course we have a ways
to go but
we have a report that's coming up and i
think we're really moving forward in a
really good way right now
any idea this is kind of parenthetical
but i've been thinking about it all day
any idea why after 70 years of
lying about it and covering this up the
military is dribbling out details like
this
is there some purpose is this part of a
pr strategy of some kind do you think
i don't look at it that way i don't
think it's any kind of orchestrated you
know strategic
move i just think a number of
circumstances happened to precipitate
this and one of the most important one
being that
luis elizondo resigned from his job at
the department of defense and revealed
the fact that he had been
heading up a program there for 10 years
this program
that was started off in 2007 you know
with the help of harry reid
and nobody knew that there was a
department in within the department of
defense or a program within the
department of defense studying ufos
until that moment
and that was a huge revelation there
were three videos that were released
from the program and it was just uh that
that's been a big change
and the military has been forced to
acknowledge things
that they wouldn't have had to admit
before that
leaking got them moving louis elizando's
on tomorrow night by the way
i agree i think he's a heroic figure uh
in the story
do you have any idea you've covered it
more than anybody why
generations of military officials felt
the need to cover this up
that's such a big and complex question
uh tucker i mean
the cover-up if you want to call it a
cover-up it began in the 40s 50s 60s
during the cold war
so there was a lot of concern to because
we were dealing with russians you know
they didn't want to have
things get mixed up with uh with all the
issues of
of russian aircraft and all the issues
within the cold war
i think there's been a concern about
what to tell people
when you can't explain something there's
something you know operating with
impunity that shows very advanced
technology what do you tell people about
that when you can't
stop it when you can't explain it uh and
i think there's also just this
there's a stigma tucker that you're well
aware of you've been one of the people
battling the stigma
where you know it's just been considered
for decades and decades to be something
ridiculous and people don't want to talk
about something that's going to
look make them look ridiculous and it
might even damage their careers
so there's so many factors that have
kept us under wraps and we're really at
an important time right now i'm so happy
to see it changing after all these years
i am too and it's important to tell the
truth no matter what people think
of it as as you will know leslie thank
you thank you for your coverage of it
appreciate it
thank you for having me of course i
think it's fascinating hard to think of
a bigger story
great to see you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else